c'est le willy wonka guyancourt toi
comme ce personnage fictif nicholas
lewin possède sa chocolaterie la
spécialité de ce chef pâtissier le
caramel sous toutes ses formes avec des
touches de chocolat pour apporter des
saveurs différentes
tout cela dans des coffrets cadeaux
comme et caramel à tartiner des caramels
bout des macarons aussi on vient de
sortir une collection de macarons tout à
base de caramel caramel aux fruits
caramels au chocolat là pour noël on a
des petits sachets de friture
donc on peut avoir des petits sachets de
qaraqosh la carotte c'est un morceau de
caramels bonbons de chocolat donc ici on
a des caractères noirs on a des nouilles
les nougats la cesam on peut aussi
retrouver les pralinés ont bien sûr mais
encore près d'un coffret de 10 prime la
magie de noël opère aussi à travers ses
bûches avec une création spéciale pour
une bûche coup les traditionnels mais
avec avec pas mal de techniques à
l'intérieur beaucoup de textures
l'acidité du citron qui envoie du peps
et à la noisette qui vient un petit peu
emporter de la gourmandise à la bûche
pour les plus gourmands nicholas lewin a
prévu cette bûche caramel cacahuètes
on est vraiment dans la gourmandise la
cacahuètes grillées salle et qu'on
travaille en plusieurs états dans un
biscuit dans un crémeux
le tout avec une mousse caramel vanillé
et phare de sel durant le dernier mois
de l'année caramel réalise près de
200000 euros de chiffre d'affaires au
mois de janvier place à la galette des
rois au menu une frangipane au morceau
d'amendé occupe de caramel fondu puis
une galette citron noisette